hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
Christmas is over and it sucks
if Halloween what's is such a great
holiday I would totally have Christmas
take that one over just like we do at
Thanksgiving but on the plus side I have
discovered a brand new holiday classic
it's not even that old but deserves to
be talked about it's cold
Arthur Christmas no god dammit I hate
how many times that happens for those of
you who actually do remember at least
the trailers you might be thinking what
that weird-looking British movie where
the characters eyes all look like toys
story screen tests tell me it's not true
well surprisingly if you give the movie
a chance not only would you find it to
be funny but it also captures the
importance of Christmas from a more
contemporary point of view as well as
kind of from a nostalgic point of view
the movie is about several generations
of Santa's and how the latest one is
getting ready to hand the reins over to
his oldest son what Santa's other son
Arthur who works in the mailing room
sees a child's been missed and so he has
to travel across the seas to try and get
the present or for Christmas along the
way he's up by his grandad and enough
from the wrapping department who takes
her job way too seriously just look at
how hardcore she is with her skills
there's no time for what follows is
magic laughs action and all sorts of
great visual wonders a pretty
straightforward story but the hard
comedy and greatness of it all lies in
the details look at how fast this comedy
is the animation is so quick but the
attention to detail and tons of little
side jokes is unbelievable
I mean look how many things they do in
just a few seconds of screen time this
is a movie you have to see three times
in order to see all the jokes and you
have to watch three more times just to
hear all the jokes bill Dale's jingle
jingle jingle drop time eighteen point
one four seconds browse gram Channel
this kid must have been good it's called
wide making the neck is right so I've
got to wrap the time converting milk and
cookies to biofuels it reminds me a lot
of hot fuzz where it's funny the first
time you see it but then when you watch
it again there's a ton of little things
you never noticed no no maybe there's
something too British comedy nowadays
that they feel they just had to do
things as fast as possible not that I'm
against at all because hey that just
means the rewatch value is made even
better sometimes comedy can be too fast
though if you don't have the right thing
to care or focus on and this movie
definitely has that too not just on the
goal of our main character but also how
three generations of extremes are
constantly at war santa's father pitch
is about how everything should be done
the old way santé son pitch is about how
everything should be done
technologically-advanced on top of the
line and Santa himself is old tired
simply looking for love and attention
while not realizing he's actually doing
very little work and at the center of it
is Arthur who doesn't care what method
is being taken as long as the toy gets
delivered so he uses any and all means
necessary he doesn't care if it's old
new or who even gets the most praise he
just wants to make sure the kid is happy
and still believes in the magic of
Christmas this is brilliant because not
only is the Battle of technology versus
hand craftsmanship still going on but it
will always be going on for years and
years so this movie shows very little
sign updating the technology to is based
off of real devices but still is their
own creation with their own unique spin
on it so even that won't be dated to bad
and like I said before the center is of
course Arthur the only one who reads the
letters to Santa and knows the love that
all the children have read and for
Christmas all around so one we should
all look to him he's gonna have all the
answers right actually no in fact he has
very few of them he's a klutz he's a
mess-up whether it's old or new he will
always find a way to screw things up but
what he does have is the spirit and the
effort and in the end it's a combination
of everybody's efforts that pulls things
through and that's why it's so good it
would have been so easy for this movie
to just pick a side say that only the
old traditional ways are best and you
can't beat the original magic or maybe
even make the older son a bad guy
because he's too greedy or something or
heck even the current Santa because he's
too forgetful and greedy but no there
are no bad guys in this they're all just
people who got lost in their work and
forgot what the purpose of their job was
to begin with they don't just slap the
word villain on any of them they're all
dedicated but just confused and I think
this is something a lot of people can
relate to especially around Christmas
time trying their hardest to pull
through on something and in doing so
losing focus of what's most important
and sure this isn't the first film to
draw attention to how the focus of
Christmas can be lost but much like
Christmas Carol it mixes the elements of
the past present and future all into
what the past being the generation that
wants to keep it the old way the present
with all the new and improved technology
and the future in terms of which methods
are going to be used and by who
and in the end it focuses on another
important element of Christmas and
that's compromise not any one way being
right but try your heart is to combine
the best elements of all of them
together mixing the strongest parts of
the old ways with the strongest parts of
the new ways in my opinion I think this
is right up there with Charlie Brown The
Grinch Christmas Carol and all those
other breaks so what if there's a lot of
current technology in it the message is
still timeless and so are its characters
it gets across a classic idea in a new
way that's all its own it has the heart
it has the labs it has the visual wonder
and it has the weight and respect of
every
magic I hope this movie becomes popular
more and more with every passing year
and when people hear the title maybe
soon this won't be the first thing
everybody thinks of if you can catch it
this year definitely be sure to check it
out the following Christmas you
certainly won't regret
I'm gonna stab your critic I ever met
wait a minute
next month is January you know what that
means tomorrow gotta get burned
killing me won't bring back their
goddamn bears not the birds I get my
prescription
he just brushes his butthole when he's
fucking iguanas doing on my coffee